best hinge prompts to use should I read
mine sure this is a really good one and
I think people should steal it the
question says the best way to ask me out
is by and I said a boom box outside my
window like every single guy says the
same thing what song am I playing or
they'll recommend a song or they'll send
me a Spotify link it literally is the
best one that they respond to ooh this
next one's a little spicy this is a new
one I just added oh I don't know it I
thought it was one I created for you
what' you what' you create I can't stand
the smell of eggs yeah that's really hot
Sophia I can't stand the smell of eggs
on a dating some people can't see I
wrote I wrote oh God the question is
dating me is like and I said getting
complimentary
dessert oh my God honestly
e Chris covered his face was hor no it
was so bad I'm changing I'm deleting how
a guy react to it